pop
[Musique]
non
me voilà excellence canard
et parce que c'est le cas d'air à la
rouennaise tout le mystère est dans la
façon de le cul oui c'est très simple au
moyen d'une construction exerçait de la
map contre le coût d'un câlin mettra les
airs ne connaîtront plus dans le corps à
tiques l'hémato se fait incompétente
je tiens à mettre des extras basse a
consenti dans le tissu cellulaire
il sait parler mais je suis jeune et
sous des lampes à quoi on va pas voulu
tordre le cou à votre canal ça ne put
rien dire comme les eaux
eh ben c'est excellent avec ça je
canards et oies mais ça c'est ma femme
elle-même qui l'a achetée oui il y
aurait vu que j'avais même oublié mon
prono
heureusement il y avait un jeune homme
très galant qui m'a prêté 6 toujours des
hommes pour les bonnes occasions mais
ces moyens pas de bonnes occasions pour
tous des hommes venus apporter vos
champagne au plateau mais mon mari le
docteur me me débrouille dit que ça
m'excite permettent au rendez vous et
c'est du vin vous avez devant vous dis
que ça il me vient de troyes aube habile
aussi célèbre par son champagne que par
le cheval du même nom et non pas pas le
cheval et champagne ça n'a aucun rapport
c'est qu'il n'aime pas la même si mon
bébé et je dis que cheval et champagne
ça s'écrivait un jour franc je ne dis
pas mais il ya 3 et 3 qui fait de la
ferme et breuil 3 francs 6
messieurs mesdames messieurs mesdames je
demande la parole seraient séparés
monsieur placard ça mon mari était fait
pour être traîné
messieurs mesdames on ne pourra pas nier
beaucoup de familles à trouver et moi
qu'ils cherchent
mais messieurs mesdames haschisch oui
bah vous allez bientôt blessés par des
hommes et femmes un ami me ferait penser
à vous leur ordre qui ont petit
messieurs mesdames et surtout toi ma
fille je vous ménage une surprise
apportez-nous les races bouche c'est ça
ta surpris bonne bonbons non c'est une
interruption aux albacete pour
m'habituer
bon si jamais je suis député ben vous
n'entendez pas j'ai demandé que vous
nous apporte à scier les rince bouche
voila voila je vais vous la porte à ces
d'abord on dit apporter non dit pas
porter c à
je pensais faire plaisir à monsieur
comme monsieur vient de le dire on
l'aimait je lis tu t'es s'illustrer dans
ta famille par la fabrication d'un opéra
ben tu a refait faust après coup nos
goûts nos étaient nés avant toi il était
tout naturel qu'il eut pris les devants
et bien ton faust j'ai résolu de le
faire jouer à l'opéra mais enrichie dans
la fabrication du sucre par
l'exploitation des diabétiques
il ne manque plus qu'un peu de lustre à
mon nom est bien seul lustres c'est toi
qui me donnera tu es mon oeuvre
cet opéra est honda or les oeuvres de
nos vins sont par conséquent fond
c'était mon âme
j'ai dit
ça vous dit pas comment tu prendras pour
le faire jouer et attend donc voilà j'ai
appris l'autre jour que l'opéra avait
l'intention d'engager un ténor
merveilles ne vois tu sais comme je sens
que j'en ai une amp temps à si elle
voulait sortir ce ténor chante à
bordeaux il s'appelle du shooto et à un
avenir immense qu'est ce que je fais je
telegraph immédiatement à mon vieil ami
du procès engage pour moi n'importe quel
prix ténor du jeton actuellement
bordeaux et expédie directement me
comprenez avec une fois en possession du
ténor je le lis à moi le pégase trail à
mes genoux et en même temps que je lui
repasse montée n'a je lui myopes ou pas
car elle qui paraissent d'ajouter
monsieur les dames à votre nom mais
prenons garde à mon col en favoris
peuvent bien embrasser centre embrasse
sa belle mère plutôt bas
les concerts fait souvent des primeurs
elle prêche pour son sein la maman
landerneau monsieur yann piat d'arrivée
de bordeaux il vient la part de monsieur
du fossé de desfossés c'est lui c'est du
château à mes amis je vous en prie
faites lui notre précieux on pensait
vingtaine à s'est habituée aux
inventions
alors martin en piano bon gros morceau
jeudi vous allez taper sur kobe bryant
n'ayez pas peur de faire du bruit dans
landerneau ya donc tu vas monter sur un
fauteuil en face de moi il va avec la
serviette
nous ferons l'arc de triomphe et rihanna
et tiburce l'idée on a nous aller
chercher les messieurs il est vous alors
qu'ils purgent tu fais entrer avec
déférence laurie à l'argent
m
et montrer notre nouvelle où elle ne
vous dérangez pas les contrarier
quantité d'eau
dean mais dont il aime ça les ovations
aller reprenons et
pas été drôle et je ne fuis pas je suis
pas rassuré sont en danger
après bien maintenant causons permettez
moi de vous présenter tout le monde si
madame landerneau ami intime qui
partagent notre maison ma femme ma fille
la dame d'oublier son porte monnaie dans
une maison qui est ce possible
pauvre femme à la les présentations sont
faites à je suis content de vous voir le
défoncer va bien à part mais au peuple
il a dit popp
pourquoi bon je vous demande si dufosset
du fossé aaa mais alors vous êtes
monsieur pas carême tard par le tibet et
moi qui croyais de chez des fous dames
c'est vrai tout sur des chaises sur la
table d'un piano on aurait cru ou julio
chat perché au musée vous faisait une
europe et c'était pourtant quelle drôle
de façon de se doit donc jeune homme n'a
rien comment vous êtes monsieur pas car
elle
enchantée aujourd'hui à propos des
lettres pour vous elle est au fond de la
mare une lettre pour moi deux du fond
c'est ce cher ami il va bien du fond
s'est admirablement eelv admirablement
mon père pourquoi m'appelle t-il sans
paix il a dû être élevé chez les
jésuites
comment le trouvez vous montez nord n'a
l'air devant de la santé je me soignerai
rôle de jean paquette aborde sommes dit
hier mon fils tu vas aller faire ton
droit à paris mais comme je ne veux pas
te laisser libre à toi même dans cette
grande ville les plaisirs effréné des
corruptions facile je t'adresse à mon
vieil ami pas car elles ont publié sur
toi sois aimable avec lui ne le
contrarie femme tu verras c'est un
charmant potes donc sur place ça c'est
vrai il en a l'air je crois que je
n'apparais rien n'avait pas vous ne
savez pas combien je suis heureux de
vous avoir marqué par des jeunes et le
fait est que depuis ce matin j'en étais
sûr qu est ce que vous voulez un oeuf
cru une contrainte seniors non merci
j'ai mis autre chose quelle drôle de
cuisine ont fait à paris dès quelle que
soit la fois on vous savez moi ma voix
jean philippe claret tout le monde ne
vit pas comme vous nous en doute pas
madame je dois être une chanteuse
il est un peu et fringues on vous donne
un tuyau rapidement d'équipés comme je
suis confus
elle a rugi elle m'a reconnu elle est
exquise mais qui est-elle cette dame
la femme de pas car elle oblige on a
présenté tout le monde en blanc dès
maintenant si vous voulez bien la table
parce que nous n'avons pas tout à fait
fini mais alors je pas déranger le
service je prendrais vous en sommes si
vous voulez c'est très gentil
tiburce servi toujours un rince bouche à
monsieur comme ça ne serait pas serait
pas obligé de reprendre à la fin du
repas messieurs dames à votre santé
attendent et on ça n'est pas fait pour
les torts à facile alors vous savez vous
n'aurez pas d'autres logements que nous
autres les papes
le parc des princes est très sain pour
la voir ainsi vous ne pouvez refuser
vous serez au premier on a compté de ma
chambre vue sur le jardin
il ya un piano aux sahraouis mais je
vous préviens il est à que danser ça
tient plus de place enfin j'y mettrai
mon large précieux avec café très
volants bouillon c'est excitant alors
fallu faire à l'aide poule mais je le
déteste ça ne fait rien ça vous tue le
broussier j'ai pas besoin de velouté
allons nous mettre au régime commenté
c'est ça soigne ton futur interprète car
c'était lé royaume
c'est cette belle jeune fille qui a fait
l'opéra contrat mademoiselle garnier
mais du français a dû vous en parler
vaguement tout cas il s'est pas étendu
c'est pas ton du débat voilà c'est elle
j'en suis bien aise beaux monuments
bien entendu il a dit bon j'en suis bien
aise oui il est charmant jeune homme de
confiance et je vous mettrais beaucoup
de fer d'arranger ça va tu es maintenant
mes amis je ne vous fait pas mais nous
avons imposé ensemble monsieur mémoire
et ça c'est beau c'est justement à
travailler cloud et vous mesdames
à tout à l'heure à tout à l'heure
et maintenant parlons sérieusement
j'irai droite au but je ne lésinerai pas
voilà ce que vous propose vous voulez
vous 3000 francs par mois moi si un don
mais 3000 francs par mois nourris logés
chauffer soigner ça vous suffit pas
qu'est ce qu'il chante
vous voulez rire moi je veux rire ah non
non non je croyais que tu sois pas
triste ils sont exigeants les ténors à
présent qu est ce qu on vous donnait à
bordeaux mon père ma maison père
vous demande ce que vous donnez 100
francs eh ben ça en france a fait 3000
commença en france a fait 3000 madame ya
30 jours par mois alors ça en fou à 32 3
me le permet je le déciderai par email
abonnez vous disons 3005 voulez-vous
3005 par mois si je le veux il était un
homme mon père me disait que c'était un
homme charmant mais je croyais pas que
sa fille tess fois acceptée vous si
j'accepte par playboy valeur ses
contenus signé le traité
et puis vous savez un traité en règle
ainsi vous parce que comme ça chacun
connaît son droit libre c'est vous qui
me ferait passer les cols l'école mais
je ne connais pas l'argot des terrains
nous stimulons un fort des dix jeux par
40 me le faut si vous quittez vous
n'ayez pas peur je ne vous quitterai pas
mais qu'est ce qu'il faudra faire pour
ça a bien chanté bac quand et où bon me
semblera chanter drôle d'idée par
exemple de payer pour ça dites-moi avez
vous voulez faire une niche à quelqu'un
a pris à l'opéra comique sans chanter ah
non maintenant non punir qui nous est
inutile qu'il s'agit se remettre à
l'enchère enfin peu importe quelles sont
mes idées acceptez-vous à ce prix là je
crois bien vu quand je pense que quand
chante à bordeaux on dit ferme ça tu vas
faire pleuvoir
vous avez signé ce petit engagement que
j'ai eu soin de rédiger n'est ce pas
gelée de 10 ans voilà ça m'est égal je
leur passerait à l'opéra alors on nous
disons devant nous x et x
on va nous mettrons les non plus tard
ont comparu les sieurs pacarel etienne
françois fabricants de sucre par
l'exploitation des diabétiques d'une
part et du ch ton qui s'adjuge temps
vous eh ben non c'est un homme théâtre à
c'est votre nom de terrain bon alors
comment vous appelez-vous dame comme mon
père mais encore dufosset parbleu but
n'achève pas malheureux j'ai compris du
fossat et on perd et ben oui puisque je
vous le dis qu'est ce qu'il a il faut
c'est son père il a un fils lui un homme
marié père de famille dockal on ne me
l'avait jamais dit voilà dont un fruit
de sa débauche c'est mon père qui m'a
dit va trouver pacarel mon père il te
permets tu as fait ton père ou dames
c'est logique est sûre c'est bien ton
père dame qu'est ce que dit sa femme
cassoulet qu'elle dise parce qu'elle
sait que son fils maman maman elle te
permets de l'appeler maman pauvre femme
et landos ils ont beau dire ils sont
tout de même un peu brac dans la famille
et le fils que dit le fils de te voir
prendre dans la famille d'une place
n'appartient qu'à lui seul le fils
qu'elle fit ce sale fils de ton père de
mon père papa un fils je les connais à
12 ans il avait 13 ans et il est
beaucoup plus petit poids un fils mais
de qui parle de sa femme tu l'a jamais
vu jamais fait six morts français 30 ans
je vais écrire un papa mais ne fait pas
ça à mano au bail manquerait plus que ça
dans la révolte adultérin contre le
légitime jean noël tu enlèves ta jupe ne
vous agitez pas ce qui est fait est fait
pour moi j'ignore tout elle ne parlons
plus deux essais ces trolls parlons plus
deux épées dû signer le traité
or vous signez du fossé ben oui bon des
fossés mettez à côté 10 du jeton pour
qu'on sache parfait alors voilà votre
été
et il va aussi le mien et maintenant
vous êtes monté nord particulier je vous
souhaite de plaisir à wimereux
moi j'ai toujours aimé à protéger les
arts
c'est sans doute pour ça que vous êtes
officiers d'académie annoncé un autre
d'une décoration que j'ai trouvée au bal
de l'opéra je les déposer chez le
commissaire personne ne l'a réclamé au
bout d'un an et un jour on m'a dit ça va
partir
voilà comment je suis officier
d'académie mes compliments
oui on sait peu de choses alors je vais
vous installer dans votre chambre à une
petite recommandation vous ne ferez pas
du piano trop bonne heure pour pas
réveiller le monde ayez pas peur j'ai le
respect dans l'antre du piano vous savez
ces dames aime ta dormir ces dames et on
et ces dames on fait comment
s'appelle-t-elle je suis absolument pas
c'est depuis ce matin et bien
abonnez-vous du fossat et voilà son
tania ouvrage je vais lui écrire
depuis que je vous ai frôlé je vous aime
là dans le panier qu'est ce que vous
faites bourbon panier de madame
landerneau moyens mal alors dénoncé la
femme de l'autre de l'autre alors je dis
pas de scrupules avoir regardé son
panier et des yeux de merlan frit
monsieur pagaret les grenats garder un
secret tu as vu si je peux pas faire
autrement je trouve madame landerneau
admire
alors oui mais c'est pas passé mais vous
n'avez pas regardé une poitrine ça n'en
finit pas ça s'en va c'est le samba de
la poitrine
vous voulez vous ensuite hockey enfin
pour la rareté du fait c'est égal lors
ellug landerneau un avis le sou lannoy
vaut cher bonpaix monsieur lannoy de
vaud mon futur gendre que monsieur du
fonds sec 1/10 près de la cale monsieur
est pas un très bon mot non monsieur ce
type de chants paysagiste alors
maintenant holnon venir il est bouché
mon genre
bush est fichue métier je vais vous dire
c'est que moi je me destine à la
peinture comme mon père à votre père se
destinant les morts il était patron
animaux oui il a même fait le portrait
de mon genre super alors je me suis fait
battre comme lui pour faire quelque
chose
moi mon père et fabricants d'alcool
alors je le suis un peu aussi je fais
surtout la bête
moi je fais l'esprit m'apparaissent
extrêmes ce tout au long du fossé mon
genre nouveau qui t'ont je vous envoie
va-t-on financer ces temps passés du
côté de chez vous plaît
maman m'a dit tu vas porter à buca ta
fiancée cdh rigueur quand on fait ça
court je l'avais bien acheté le bouquet
mais en venant j'ai fait accrocher
jusqu'au chez camélia et elle l'a
ramassée mont bouquet lé charme aux
camélias et sans façon avec elle je ne
suis pas obligé de tourner ma langue
sept fois dans sa bouche c'est pas comme
ici où maman m'a bien recommandé de le
faire chaque fois que j'ai à parler
quelle idée aussi de vouloir me marier
c'est stupide cas mais il ya aussi tout
ça stupide elle m'a dit regarde moi est
ce que je me marie et elle a même ajouté
si jamais je commençais à marier ce ne
serait qu avec toi elle a appelé sa
bonne pour faire les cartes
savez-vous ce qu'elles ont dit les
cartes si la noix de veau smar il sera
malheureux s'il reste avec camélia il
sera toujours heureux et ça m'a coûté 20
francs pour la bonne
vous comprenez je veux pas aller contre
les destins papa m'a dit va retrouver
confiance et iman nuit mon fiancé y
bégaie et ajouté papa observatoire
tiens-toi droite et compte deux fois
jusqu'à 4 entre toutes tes paroles
la fidh packard bell tourner sept fois
la langue bonjour mademoiselle
commentait les volumes 2,3 de catherine
ii iii iv très bien je vous remercie et
vous ça qu'est ce qu'elle a je vous
avais apporté un bouquet seulement je me
suis aperçu qu'il était fan et alors je
les jetais dieu qu'il est agaçant avec
son pitch in de trois quarts est ce que
c'est tout de même d'être musicienne
elle bat la mesure tout le temps de
trois carrefours de 3,4 et madame votre
mère a bien ce qu'elle est crispante
très bien
mais sa propre frère est très malade
avec salle a perdu sa meilleure amie à
l'achat grain elle ne sait plus sur quel
pied danser in de 3,4 et de 3,4 à long
terme tant mieux il doit avoir une
paralysie de la langue
non mais vous ne voyez toute ma vie au
bras à gré de cette petite inde quand on
est cinq minutes avec l ombre de rien à
lui dire mieux vaut mourir cela ferait
une deux trois quatre et une de 3 4 vous
anglais pas aussi fin c'est dans ma
nature je la tuerais l'observateur pas
toujours que j'aime explique le pourquoi
des choses à 6 voyez vous en ce moment
je suis en train de faire des études
sans explication d'un phénomène que vous
avez dû remarquer sûrement si vous en
avez une expérience et 3,4 une deux
trois quatre fers pourquoi la mite
paquet blanche devient telle noir quand
on la houle entre ses doigts quelques
russes mon fiancé une deux trois quatre
pin de 3,4 je n'ai pas fait d'études
spéciales et non pas que je les pousse
jamais lu te prononcer mais veut que la
prend pour femmes me dire à quoi êtes
vous dit non par les après vous madame
andernos tout à l'heure à bibiche madame
g 20 ne fait pas attention monsieur pas
car elle m'a prié pour la bienséance de
jeter un coup d'oeil par là mais sans
les troubles et en ayant l'air de ne pas
avoir l'air mart viendra après on ne
croirait pas mademoiselle mais pas cette
chaleur genou jusqu'à 4 gillett fanel
par jour
depuis que je vous épauler je vous aime
celui c'est le ténor odieux l'imprudent
il m'écrit j'avais bien vu que vous
regardez depuis que je vous ai frôlé
mais oussama type folie dieu ça doit
être l'inconnu que j'ai croisé un jour
d'orage dans la colonne vendôme et vous
a tellement noir que je n'ai pu le voir
mais j'ai entendu sa voix car il s'est
écrié
tiens on a mis un bouchon dans la
colonne
ah oui celui-là il affolait
et bien pauvre jeune homme singe
impitoyable pas pu la voir madame et
bien voyons qu allez vous en dire
je n'ose pas parler d'abord je n'ose pas
non plus j'aime mieux vous l'écrire et
moi aussi
voilà du papier
la voilà c'est fait l'on ne force pas
ses sentiments
nous avons dû nous tromper de papier non
ne force pas ses sentiments
nous ne sommes pas faits l'un pour
l'autre elle est bien bonne freiner mais
parmi vous non plus manqué je suis
heureux dit donc de froid c'est que je
ne vous avais pas moi je pourrais vous
en dire autant
mais les n'ai pas peur je ne vous en
veux pas aux fêtes dites donc vu votre
tic tic
oui vous savez bien comme ça oh c'est
pratique c'est une précaution
c'est maman qui me l'ordonné de 3,4
c'est une recommandation de papa aubin
j'aime autant ça je me disais aux
pauvres jeunes à voter comme moi je
pensais c'est pas possible
elle a avalé un métronome comme nous
avons nous entend maintenant que nous
épousons plus je crois bien ami ami et
maintenant celui d'un diplomate jusqu'à
nouvel ordre pour tout le monde nous
restons fiancé c'est le seul moyen de
conserver notre liberté nous auront tout
le loisir de prendre une décision
entendue donc comme si de rien n'était
je ne vous dérangez pas didon fillette
tu n'as pas vu le ténor non je le
cherche pour que je lui rende ses six où
il n'y a pas un morceau papier pour un
voleur de psy plus convenable pour
remettre de l'argent vient nous restons
fiancée aux yeux du monde et maintenant
une deux trois quatre
une deux trois quatre je vous demande la
permission de vous quitter et fait donc
je tiens en passant elle est charmant il
gagne beaucoup comme ami je suis
forcément fatale ma mère m'a tant
une lettre d'amandine quand elle était
en italie avec son mari si vous savez
que de bible où j'ai acheté des caisses
pleines
je sens que je fais des folies que j'en
ferai d'autres ne dit rien de mon mari
je ne dis rien non plus soigner mon
frein et si vous voulez être tout à fait
adorable ht/mois une paire de jaar
diable je vous embrasse amandine
landerneau russe a donc l'important
c'est comme ça enveloppé de jugement
j'aurai la chance était avec moi madame
landerneau non si les messieurs pas car
elle qui a voulu précisément pour que je
ne prenne pas froid que le panier on a
touché au panier elle a dû trouver le
billes
je lui rende c6 ou monsieur madame je
cherchais à cause de ce que j'ai voici
de vous mon billet au madame j'espère
que vous ne vous êtes pas offenser on ne
se fera jamais d'une galerie ce que j'ai
fait via l'audacieux ah non j'ai pas
trouvé
à vous l'avez diable et les cuirassés
c'est que vous comprenez quand on ne
connaît pas n'est ce pas j'ai pas osé en
mettre davantage mais je n'ai pas besoin
le tard il faut rien de plus
le tarif hagarde tarif est ce que ce
n'est pas comme ça bon d'où mon dieu non
je ne comprends rien à ce qu'elle me dit
j'aurais besoin de me faire aux
habitudes de paris à deux tarifs c'est
tout être bien n'accommode on doit
jamais s'entendre aussi c'est une
question sympathie avec le conducteur
on dirait temps elle appelle ça un
conducteur c'est un type c'est égal je
suis heureux que vous ne soyez pas
froisser - est bon que voulez-vous
jeunes fois ce après tout vous n'avez
chercher quand même obligé un certain
nombre diable même façon désigne les
shows la poste n'ait pas voulu être en
reste avec vous il ya mon tour voilà un
billet elle m'a répondu au père partant
à paris en brûlant brune c'est la
névrose la fameuse les bronzes mais
pourquoi tel mis des petits cailloux
dedans elle n'atteint vous quitte je
regarderai ça toute ma vie
ah ouais
ça ça vous regarde
l'économie d'une belle qualité
au revoir et merci que peut-elle me dit
enfin des cailloux ce sont les six où
elle aurait pu les garder
je sens que je fais des folies et que
j'en ferai d'autres
est il possible en chaire anges ne dit
rien à mon mari tient par bhl pas si
bête
je ne dis rien non plus j'espère bien
soigné bien mon frein son frein
ça doit être son mari elle a une façon
d'appeler les choses certainement je me
soignerai ton sera c'est dans l'ordre à
ça et si vous voulez être tout à fait
adorable voyons ht/mois une paire de
jarretière bleus
une peine mais je crois bien les
textiles une perle
on trouve ça qu'à paris mais je vais
courir lui en acheter des masses je vous
embrasse signé amandine lambert nos eaux
mater normandie pour savoir où il va je
te donnerai des jarretières
donnez les jarretières oui j'en ferai
venir à lomé qui même à diamant dit tu
m'aimeras mari madame qu'est ce qu'il
manque quelque chose à celle là tu
regardes songer à timide et enfin c'est
à dire j'aime mon mari mais non
détriment des autres amitié ah non non
j'ai des pages non je ne rougis pas
ainsi quand je vais dans la colonne
bandeau ne franchissait pas je ne le
suis pas souvent se croise on se rend
compte une fois entre autres il
descendait je montais je me suis effacé
norbourg comment avez vous fait mal et
le vernis cépages nobles je ne renie pas
voudrait faire passer par toutes les
couleurs et de sa promo a jaillit
l'étincelle
je n'ai pu le voir lui mais j'ai entendu
sa voix je n'a bon quelques couleurs à
présent je leur dise up pour voir
tiens on a mis un bouchon dans la
colonne tient la mia bouchons dans la
colonne s'est pas du tout savoir mais
c'est sans doute parce qu'il nous manque
la colle nom sonne peut-être
non mais pour femmes racontent elles
tout ça à vous dire combien ce frôlement
dans la colonne m'a brisé mike rasé ça
m'étonne pas c'est si étroits depuis ce
souvenir nantais je me sens des effluves
de sang qui me remonter des battements
lala parfaitement ben j'ai connu une
dame qui avait ça à bordeaux on lui a
fait des purgation et quelques mois
après elle accouchait équipe possible
le sial m'empressais au je crois que
j'ai trop brusquer toute l'année vous
avez des amis je suis aux anges
il a une foire où tu l'as fait chanté oh
non non non mais je n'ai entendu tous
ces mails un troll
alors j'ai immédiatement écrit au
directeur de l'opéra abondamment d une
audition à priay des syndicats que j'ai
mon cher du fond c'est oui c'est vrai de
tous les tradi il est le fils naturel de
dufaux c'est un garçon croyez que je
prends bien failli tromper même qu'est
ce qui l'a le médecin à propos de quoi
rien études je respecte les blessures
vous avez raison ça regarde les
chirurgies quelle drôle de famille dites
donc vous allez bien nous chanter
quelque chose - vous n'y pensez pas
comment c'est bien le moins
quel sacré manie sans douleur va faire
chanter à me si vous ne refuserait pas à
moi elle mais je n'ai pas de voix on a
toujours cela
je vous accompagnerai nous sommes à 3 1
devant canon j'aurais bien tout ça mais
non je vous jure l accompagnement et ben
c'est que je vais vous dire oui
les pianos ils sont tous fois à côté de
ma voix nous était romanow a donné bien
du bonheur mais je vous en donnerai des
jarretières
ça n'était qu'un jeu c'est un peu ça lui
d'honneur chaste et pur au chômage les
faits qu'est ce qui vous attire
je ne suis qu faire déjà le nomade
voilà déjà tous mais la cour a marre
toile je surveillerai or bâtonnets comme
c'est déjà beau comme en haussant le
grand ténor sept mecs qui se saluent
demeure chaste et pur
salut demeure chaste et pur achat ou sa
petite sortie recherche
[Musique]
salut de norge as they put
salut
demeure chaste et pur
oussad battez vous descendez à moi je
descends toujours oui mais c'est
toujours comme ça vaut pour les grands
chanteurs on modifie l epa mot à mot
voulez vous recommencez mademoiselle j'y
suis
salut
[Applaudissements]
malheureux enfin c'est bon parce qu'on
va aller déranger les scellés ce canton
ou alors maintenant si vous voulez
salut demeure chaste et pur
salut
la chanteuse un courant d'air s'anime un
peu sans mendiants il a raison tu
connais pas les seuls
g
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
encore un point et j'ai fini que ces
bêtes la vie on admet qu'un amant aime
sa maîtresse on n'admet pas qu'un
domestique aime sa maîtresse pourtant le
mot helmet où est la nuance
amandine tu ne m'as pas compris ce que
j'aime en toi c'est ta surface on doit
aimer pour deux avec toi tu fais du
profit mais un jour j'ai eu l'audace de
t'avouer mon amour tu m'appeler ruy blas
et tu m'as envoyé promener
alors pour me consoler ne me reste plus
de temps en temps quand tu n'es pas là
qu'à faire des points dans ta tapisserie
danton soir je sais bien que tu t'es
fait chaque fois mes points mais ça
m'est égal je recommence
et ça me fait du bien eh ben tu perds ce
qu'est ce que vous faites là rien eu
mais madame vois je tape isma tapisserie
vous avez de l audace et moi qui me
demandait toujours qui me faisait des
points à londres c'était moi maintenant
c'était moi j'étais si heureux de
collaborer avec madame comment ils osent
aller aller et ça nous arrive oui madame
dix ans cette femme là ne mènera jamais
une femme si forte enchère au mali vrai
que tu me pèse
mauvais at on idée de slaves cet ouvrage
l'auteur du post
il met ça dans mon panier mais
l'imprudent n'aurez qu'à troupe ya des
personnes dans cette maison pas baby gym
pas d'absolu manquant j'avoue pas madame
vous avez bien voulu m'encourager joris
elle a pas l'air de vente en magasin ils
se disent que moi je comprends pas ce
garçon il est si éloquent dans ses
écrits et la copie dans sa discipline
est les dons sont comme une pioche
madame avec est ce que vous avez à crier
comme ça mais je vous demande pardon
mais voilà deux fois que je suis sur
alors j'ai un peu élevé le susurrements
et vous allez bien madame oui oui c'est
bon tout à l'heure je veux rizka et moi
j'étais très souffrant tout la nage
peut-on mieux vaut merci elle a pas pu s
occuper de moi un jour on n'est pas
tranquille
accordez-moi cette nuit une entrevue
dans la serre 1
vous pourriez pas me dire oh moi où je
pourrais trouver ma fiancée dont la
seule dans la serre vous remercie bel a
rejoint vannes doute de rien
je vous jure que ce sera en tout bien
tout honneur
oui ça c'est des bêtises réfléchissez je
suis un gars lenteur oui ça très galant
très galant si vous consentez dites à
votre mari d'agiter son mouchoir dans il
verra en chantant à votre choix
coli façon borg ou coucou à le voile et
vous indiquerez leur part autant de ré
que vous trace real à crêpes dans son
dos vous me rendrez bienheureux au bon
je vous dis l'été l'aube quand dans ses
écrits à propos j'ai trouvé des
jarretières mais on demande la mesure il
les petits gars déjà routière qu'est ce
que tu lis la ville comment rien j'étais
bien vu il essaie peut-être que tu
caches ria je te dis à papier sans
importance alors pourquoi la plus
vivement dissimulait mal à penser que je
le montre le moi je peux pas bonne tu me
fais supposée des choses en garde je
veux ce biais n'aurait pas un bandit tu
me trop fort cette lettre est une lettre
d'amour
j'aurais pourtant bien cru à l'abri on
voit ça j'ai perdu
le ténor et l'oci et puis après tout
tant pis cette lettre n'est pas pour moi
pas pour toi et pour qui êtes vous
capable de conserver un secret jusqu'à
la mort et même après et bien cette
lettre ou malades pas car c'est vrai au
moins ça après tout ça ne m'étonne pas
il lui a dit je vous aime devant moi
donc il se peut bien que c'est également
le sort est sapée par blanc en béton
souvient mme anna packard abbey dawn va
pas ça je me gênerait à cette impasse
reid pourquoi ce biais pour elle je lui
remets c'est tout naturel et on a la
grâce de dieu mais je fais fuir votre
femme
oui le nom
les ventes robert il va bien oui n'est
pas encore rentré il est pas la pire
c'est en ce moment pour se défausser pas
son audition il mon mari a tenu à
assister à son triomphe et l'eau il a
une voix si merveilleuse parce que tu
bordeaux parce que moi maintenant vous
savez il ya une différence de climat
et puis on a peut-être besoin de s'y
faire c'est la méthode italie
apparemment à part ça c'est un garçon
bien charmant maryland
pas étonnant c'est toujours comme ça
propos voici un petit mot qu'il m'a
chargé de vous remettre mes yeux il faut
à tout prix que je vous parle
oui je sais ce que c'est c'est un
renseignement je lui avais demandé à ses
traits oui merci
c'était bien pour elle j'aime mieux ça
n'a pas été de confier des lettres
compromettantes à un tiers
heureusement que l'on dit on ne s'est
pas méfié eh bien vous savez y était pas
dans la serre tiens c'est plus bibiche
c'est madame pas car elle madame madame
que fait-il m'écrire à balai comme
l'autre raddad
il faut à tout prix que je vous parle 1
elle y aussi ce cabinet de lecture et il
faut à tout prix que je vous parle vous
avez bien voulu bienvenus
bien voulu m'encourager je me risque
quand j'avais 12 ans je dis ça je
suppose c'est une circulaire
mais là vous avez au non non je ne
connais que cette phrase voilà tout
quelques lettres de quémandeurs oui
justement c'est sans importance et vous
allez bien aujourd'hui géré future
belle-mère
oui oui très bien je remercie mais moi
j'étais très souffrant toute la nuit
elle entend y est vous pourriez pas me
dire oh moi où je pourrais trouver ma
fiancée madame landerneau m'a dit
qu'elle était dans la sttr elle n'y
était pas dans la serre nous n'ont en
effet le jour on n'est pas tranquille
vous pourriez pas me dire où je pourrais
la trouvez-vous qu'il est temps de guy
ma fiancée au grenier au grenier
quelle drôle d'idée devait la rejoindre
madame et monsieur au malheureux
accordez-moi pour cette nuit une
entrevue dans la serre il faut google
prend t-il
je vous jure que ce sera en tout bien
tout honneur
en tout bien tout
je me disais aussi réfléchissez je suis
un gagnant tom aux non je ne peux pas
qu'est ce qu'on dirait et la nuit c'est
très dangereux il est tout bien tout
honneur
oui mais d'un autre côté si je n'y vais
pas je fais une avanie puisqu'il nous
dit je suis un régal ans tom j'aurais
l'air d'en douter dans lé coni à laon il
se trouve engagée et bijoux sera plus
polie de ma part et puis ce sera
peut-être pas ennuyeux
si vous consentez dites à votre mari
d'agiter son choix quand il ne verra en
chantant à votre choix colimaçon byrne
koukoua le volant à il faudra que ben
oui c'est lui qui donnera signal oh non
je fais un scrupule va apprécier le fait
de ne pas agiter trop fort ça atténue
vous m'indiquer leur part autant de vrai
que vous tracez à la craie dans son dos
oh non non ça mange dort jamais
rahim maryse impro bon j'ai bien trouvé
des jarretières mais on demande la
mesure
décidément il peut être actionnée dans
une fabrique marthe est là rien dû
comprendre
j'en ai le coeur net
venez de la classe
moi voilà
voilà comme ça c'est bien
vous avez lu mon mari ah oui il a dû
vous remettre un billet 1
comment savez vous je le sais parce que
je les ai eues entre même à vous l'avez
dit damphousse et des français on n'a
pas idée de faire la chaîne avec ces
choses
monsieur biya je ne vais pas lui respire
pas plus que vous j'espère moi donc il
me prenez-vous je ne lis pas les billets
tu sais comme moi j'ai des principes ne
doute de rien j'ai sauvé el harga vu
chez tranquille mais ce billet j'ai
déchiré
que vouliez vous que jean fils oh pas
vous auriez pu me remettre tient au
limousin mais tous les plus dignes de
déchirer après tout je m'en moque je les
lui du temps s'était sans doute quelques
déclarations d'un amour est timide et
bien non pas sur ce coup on n'est pas
responsable des sentiments qu'on inspire
oh oui mais non vous illusionner c'est
inadmissible mais pourquoi dont ils vous
pleurez cet amour une fut pas difficile
à l'objet n'ont vraiment pas la peine
l'objet
voilà une façon et commence sa part la
peine merci ces gens disent que vous
dites là mais il n'ya pas d'illusions si
oui il faudra battre on est plus femme a
excité les passions et haines
impertinente par sachet s'il vous plaît
qu'on est aussi bien en état d'exciter
les passions certaines personnes fait la
fatuité
tout le monde le dit pas comme vous
si la colonne vendôme vous pouvez parler
cette colonne vendôme n'a rien à faire
là que je me montre partout parce que
moi je n'avance rien sans pièces à
l'appui
c'est très facile de parler mais ce
qu'il faut c'est prouvé alors tout le
monde m'en sortirais pas de sa poche des
colonnes vendent au mhr je trouve que
vous avez dit très déplacé je ne me gêne
pas pour vous le dis ok antoine amis et
le défend même contre moi même alors il
va mettre je n'ai rien dit internautes
vous avez dû abjuré pays là tout ça
n'est pas sérieux
vrai c'est pas sérieux quand va-t-on
vieux parce que ça me faisait de la
peine
vous ne direz plus qu'on n'est pas prêt
à faire des pas sur rien on l'a mais ça
ça se dit c'est qu'on ne pas avoir l'air
de se faire des compliments
qu'est ce que ça fait entre nous bon eh
bien je dirais si vous voulez on est la
plus belle la plus charmante la musique
ce qu'ils aient toutes les femmes vous
aller dans l'excès à l'autre passable
seulement comment part ça n'a pas des
attraits des attraits m'enfin je vous
assure qu'on comprend très bien qu'un
homme pas trop vieux ou encore très
jeune cas pas trop l'embarras du choix
enfin voilà les choses comme ça voyez
plutôt la colonne devant la colonne la
colonne montrait même la base qui nous
allons nous
qu'avez-vous n'ont toujours pour août
vous avez vous on ne va pas ainsi des
gens vous êtes trop indulgent pour moi
que des sujets étaient trop loin je
retire le fait est que j'ai été un peu
sévère quelle excellente arme il vient
de rentrer il a l'air tout bouleverser
tu m as a réussi quelques coups bas il a
passé son audition
ça c'est du propre mes amis désastre je
m'étais attendue à ça mais déjà hier je
me disais bien et c'est drôle poids
oscillant d'erlon tu me le disent mais
je pensais que nous ne sommes pas
connais seulement puisqu'il a une belle
voix et bain puisqu'il est célèbre et je
t'en fiches à des réputations comme
celle là comme la copie faut dire aussi
des bordeaux n'est ses cibles alors
alors alors alors nous arrivons donc à
l'opéra le directeur nous reçoivent et
on passe dans la salle paris avec nous
deux et le jury le jury était composé
des directeurs du chef d'orchestre et
d'un pompier qui se promenaient mais ce
dernier ne devrait avoir que voix
consultative car n'ayant pas été
interrogés il n'a pas émis d'avis le
chef d'orchestre était chargé
d'accompagner il demandait du fond c'est
qu'elles sont les airs qu'ils chantent
ils répondent qu'ils possèdent assez
bien il n'est ni rangnick avait ni
pointu interprète dans le trou
alors on lui objecte que ça fait pas
partie du répertoire
il fait tant pis il se rabat sur son
éternel ça lui vient alors moi je me
sens et si d'inquiétude peuvent ce n'est
pas si bien marché ici alors je me dis à
la grâce de dieu
il a chanté sans passion on peut appeler
ça chantait parce que c'était faux les
pas en mesure et il a eu beau prétend
que c'est le piano qui était faux et
l'accompagnateur qui allait trop vite ça
n'a pas mordu du pendant ce temps le
directeur sont gardés à ulee lheu
pompiers lui disait rien bah il n'avait
pas l'air satisfait compte un
accompagnateur il était en moiteur il
aimait à des tons mais allez donc est la
fin du fossé a dit fritz
je sentais que tout le monde me
regardait ont été couverts de honte
et quand je suis parti on m'a dit que le
théâtre n'était pas un atelier pour les
fumistes le banc ni calme-toi que
devient super cela mieux ça qui me
tracassait je dois faire va te comprends
bien parce que enfin j'ai un traité avec
lui dans un traité qui me mit comme un
mouton viso 3500 francs par mois
tu parles c'est peu de chose pour hâter
lorsqu'il n'a pas de voix et on a pas
mal rêve qu'est ce qu'il chante un drap
à landerneau bien sûr ce ne sera pas moi
alors que quand même pas traiter avec
tous les ténors libre d'engagement pour
te trouver un interprète la faune dans
une agence alors qu'avant qu'elle
exagère les choses du fou c'est
peut-être fatigué le changement de
climat on ne sait pas mais ce voyage est
arrivée didier tu ne m'as pas laissé le
temps de souffler tu comprends que si
les célèbres à bordeaux c'est qu'il a
quelque chose et 1 0 et une défaite
jolie acquisition lui lui les angels
laissez-nous seul et moi voilà monsieur
gilbert deleu fin afin de bien ça
c'est moi qui doit nourrir les bouches
d'inutiles la boue ne rougissez pas
votre état de parasites parasites m'a
dit ah oui oui vous vanter d'avoir été
par les envies d'ailleurs à mon dieu tu
me trouves ça a été bien lourd vous
n'êtes pas difficile mais pas vu la tête
que c'est le pompier j'en doute tant que
monsieur ben aussi vous n'aviez qu'à pas
me faire chanter mais dites donc temps
que les ténors ont pas fait pour serrer
des bottes injustement chacun son métier
il était facile de s'apercevoir que je
n'étais pas en état
il ya pas de lire nous aurions attendu
quelques temps mais je plaisante
nous autres bordelais on dit blagueur
comme un parisien alors je me suis fait
cette réflexion pas car elle fait une
blague à l'opéra au bâton en bois ton ah
oui robin et anthony jean joly par
réflexion qu'est ce que je vais faire de
vous maintenant pensez bien je vais pas
vous héberger et vous payez pour vos
beaux yeux
quant à la terreur il faut plus y penser
alors regardez moi ça
je sais vous savez faire vous avez une
belle écriture
vous savez compter 25 et 9,7 et combien
with guns tombe sur qui compter sur toi
non mais avec les doigts c'est plus
comme un temple camarades alors il
suffit qu'on est à trois mois est pris
hier une opération juste
mais qu'est ce que ça cache derrière là
je suis parent vous trouverez une
occupation cas si vous voulez vous ferai
les courses une matin je voudrais faire
une chambre donne rien de plus beau moi
oui combien vous rendre utile à quelque
chose prendre des deux ténors à 3500
francs comme domestiques ces raids
on aurait un [ __ ] pour moins cher et ça
fait plus d'effet
au menu milliers de la sorte c'est trop
fort je vais écrire à papa beauté de
l'onu vous savez pas moins à tiburce est
à toi tu dégages que je vous donne
il aurait plus qu'à voir les mêmes
prétentions en remercie moi je pouvais
arriver alors passer à quelqu'un paie
chine
c'est trop fort ce matin une choix yens
métal et vouloir maintenant il me reçoit
comme un chien dans un jeu de quilles o
vous êtes en colère c'est votre père
mademoiselle niveau de jeu sur les
parquets que je passe les jambes repère
un peu plus il m'appelait l'arbre
nouveau jeune homme pape allemand ce pas
ce qu'il dit peut-on faire de la peine
ainsi gentil gars m'a profondément
offensé et six jeunes étaient retenus
par les charmes d'une personne que
possible une jeune personne une jeune
personne mais je ne peux pas la nommer
non mais ne met pas dérougi j'aurais
vraiment pas de quoi
amandine doit avoir reçu mon billet
maintenant quelles lois telles pensées
je suis bien heureuse du là que vous
venez de me faire pour bien heureuse et
je vous sais gré de votre discrétion
la discrétion est la première des
qualités de l'homme n'empêche qu'elle
doit bien savoir qui c'est la petite je
suis bien heureux mais moi je meurs duff
qui vient de sortir de là mais c'est du
faux c'est il a eu cette fois pas il est
profondément blessé
il est allé manger ça prouve qu'il a
bien que n l'appétit
ton père nie pas là non tu cherches oui
j'aurais besoin de lui pour le marquer
je me suis approvisionner créé dans le
bigard
[Applaudissements]
vous mangerez plus tard j'allais aider
des murs à nettoyer les hannetons encore
des parasites inutile cela au moins
autant d'effets comme mon ami c'est fini
je ne me reconnais pas alors il est
toujours je sens que mon mari a des
soupçons
je crois qu'il se doute de votre amour
coup part parbleu c'est moi qui lui ai
dit un but malheureux belle et quand et
comment a t'il pris ça lui que je
voulais que ça lui fasse il a dit
seulement et bat pour la rareté du fait
la seule jambe et j'aurais bien tort
d'avoir des scrupules
monsieur j'attends vos jarretière 58
ça me fait bien plaisir ils en ont la
manie des jarretières dans cette maison
où la nana népal battant à l'aider
tiburce parce qu'après j'ai une course à
vous faire faire moi mais vous voudrais
m'acheter une perte de jarretière je
n'ai pas craqué lui aussi a lancé dans
le sang
[Applaudissements]
partir pourquoi pas le pauvre garçon
pourquoi ça le bronze garçon tu sais ce
qu'ils gagnent pour ce qu'il me fait
3500 francs par mois alors que tu diras
tiburce qui n'a que 5 ans
la preuve on dénombre je te dise tu mets
cannes égoïste ah oui ces trois villes
très vilain rêve inassouvi le oui oui
mais moi pas pauvre garçon je les
retrouve au jardin lui porter une parole
de consolation mais moi je vais chercher
mon mari je m'en vais y a tant donné
pour la rareté du vin
vous n'êtes pas de plaindre vous sauf
que c'est moi qui soit plein temps
qu'est ce que je vais en faire
maintenant
personne n'en voudra monter à peut-être
pas au théâtre
pourquoi faire un ténor qui n'a pas de
croire justement de patron monsieur b
dans tous les commerces et toujours
moyen de requinquer un rossignol ainsi
papa qui était maquille on quand il
avait une rose à revendre il lui mettait
un grain de gingembre sous la queue
ça faisait la fête enfin j indique ce
remède à monsieur un jour merci je
n'arrive pas à me proposer
adam pour le moment mais je venais dire
à monsieur que monsieur la noire et elle
m'a fait entrer la noix futur beau-père
future belle-mère
vous venez pas votre fiancée wifi govou
n'est pas de chance je l'attends duo
grenier n'était pas un noir est au bar
d'un attention à pas dire de bêtises le
remède à maman je n'y apporte ce bouquet
à ma fiancée je serais si heureux de
l'avoir enfin julie me l'avait bien dit
je m'étais jamais à bercy et au fond du
jardin elle regarde depuis les habitants
vous avez beaucoup de boutons
ont ils écrit ce poème sont il n'y a pas
de remède à sa part de bouillante et on
est le show de ça q radicalement de
l'eau bouillante en plein traitement non
non j'ai entendu parler d'autre chose
nommée démosthène qui mettait des petits
cailloux vous pourriez essayer pour yann
ton nom ô combien de temps dans votre
machin ne vous inquiétez pas je vais
trouver mademoiselle julie lessard a dit
non et non hollande y pense
vous n'auriez pas besoin d'un terrain
non maman cherche un cuisinier amateur
pour passer un conteneur famille de
dingues gaillard effet des courtes mais
le ténor aux riches anti peu à combien
se demande 3500 francs par mois c'est
pour rien 1 pour un cuisinier mais il
est fou mais sans le vin il blanchit
sahara ce tarif là sous aucun prétexte
que 10 personnes personne entrain bon je
me sens si vous entendez qui pouvait
seulement retrouver pour 24 heures
savoir si on pouvait
avec du gingembre valaisanne fait égal
qui avait plus de 20 à 30 ans une fois
que je l'aurai casey serait peut-être
temps de parler à mon mari pour le
signal faut-il dire oui décidément obama
ferait tant pis oui mais comment faire
didot alors tu voudrais bien que dufaux
s'y retrouve sa voix
j'ai peut-être moins bien je ne garantis
rien tu sais je te donne pense qu'il est
dangereux de l'empirisme d'ailleurs
c'est une pièce de catherine graciet
d'âge est infaillible
quand un chanteur perd sa voix il y à un
moyen bien simple de la lui rend bien et
vient comment des chaussées entrera
alors tu éviteras dans mon choix comme
ça
en disant trois fois coucou alors voilà
ah oui et puis c'est tout oui c'est tout
bas il est stupide compagne à 5 ou 10 au
lieu de les aider oui enfin cette arme
est de bonne femme au point où on enlève
j'ai serré ça lui fera toujours pas de
mamans à l'honneur après tourne toi
voilà tous les jeudis crevettes sur toi
rien et maintenant que j'avais vu double
maintenant du fossé sera pas
bon alors tu as bien compris
mon choix oui oui oui les bijoux des
bagues gens qui se remet de la réussite
je renonce à la médecine c'est idiot mon
dieu que les femmes sont des pics et à 3
heures blanches ont adressé leur mon
mari ronfle
bon alors je vous laisse
à
que tu fais avec son mouchoir à la main
et toi ah non moi rien moi j'attends que
j'étais revenu
on n'a pas idée comme cbc du fossé que
j'attends avec pourrait on pas vu que je
te dise moi aussi on se serait vrai au
palu à un homme de science ça me rassure
il paraît qu'un ajoutant le mouchoir
ça rend la voix ah oui oui oui oui oui
mais il faut chanter trois fois coucou
me voilà non pas six non non non mon
bébé je ne m'a pas parlé de ça babychou
blier ah non non il m'a dit qu'il
fallait chanter colimaçon bord nous
montre moi tes cordes à banias fait des
variants vie attendront jetant la
médecine samedi un accord au fait je
n'aurais jamais cru par exemple sur le
voilà
en valais comme une animation de l'école
de balles la femme credif piste à l abri
du rand paul vatine vous pouvez prouver
quelque chose je crois bien je sens que
tout ce qui l'attend au croyable aguiton
les empires imaginaire les malades
on essaie donc plus on verra mieux
savourer oui c'est pour votre bien à
l'épreuve il est étonnant ce mari wim de
troy le rendez vous est à 3 1
la voilà allons bon il y en a deux la s2
s3 j'ai convié à partager entre les 2 et
3 et 3,5 5,6 bien ça 5 le rendez vous
est à ça le plaisir
[Applaudissements]
l'édifice est mon ami écouter ça il a
retrouvé sa foire aux cerises signé les
concerts commencé pour qu'il entende
avant vernant longtemps joueur aussi la
loi a ajouté me touche parce qu'il
chante chante depuis son retour et sa
voix je serai exact voici mon quartier
mais qu'allez vous pensez du mois moi
rien du tout je tiens on l'a mis à
bouchon dans la colonne décidément c'est
un titre tiens on a mis un bouchon dans
la colonne nous sommes peut-être que lui
un jeune homme devrait être bien coup
pas longtemps mieux tant mieux et les
cantons peuvent revenir et maintenant je
retourne aux ânes temps aux atours vous
jamais de la vie des murs avant ça qu'on
soit rare est venue du fond c'est la
gloire à landerneau
à
je ne pense pas
[Applaudissements]
aux pronostics j'ai mal dormi toute la
nuit il m'a semblé qu'on marchait dans
la maison je fais des cauchemars
j'ai rêvé que à l'épousé bibiche elle
était encore plus en cher que d'habitude
alors voilà que là surgit une belle-mère
il y avait la tête de landerneau elle
était contre le mariage alors il ya eu
un crêpage de chignon relevé allongé un
coup de poing je me sens encore j'ai
tapé sur le mur
[Musique]
voyons voir qu'est ce que ça veut dire
quand on rêve de belle-mère voyons dans
la clé des songes c'est infaillible je
connais une nourrice à qui elle avait
prédit que son fils remuerait des
millions est devenu croupier
voyons voyons voyons belle-mère elmer
bel bel mais voyez bassinois bassinois
voyez belle mère ça peut durer longtemps
comme ça monsieur packard est énorme
le sont encore descendues l'argent je
comprends pas il est près de mon heure
et personne n'est encore en bas comme si
on avait veillé toute la nuit je crois
entre nous si on dort si longtemps
aujourd'hui c'est parce que hier la
cuisinière n'ayant plus de caramel pour
colorer son couillaud yami de laudanum
île autonome vous êtes vous oui monsieur
delon d'un homme alors c'est parce que
vous racontez aujourd'hui et puis
d'abord on dit du laudanum comment du
haut et du féminin on ne dit pas du lot
de vie basé mois du lot on dit de
l'autre vie de l'eau d'un homme la
grammaire est la même pour les
domestiques comme pour les mettre
quel idiot blanche m'en vais vous êtes
en train de balayer je tiens pas à
avaler tous vos micros monsieur peut
rester quand je balaie je prend toujours
soin de ne pas déplacer la poussière
d'hayange et filles ah oui c'est ce qu'a
d'agréables avec cette manière de
balayer quand on veut on a toujours fini
la voici monsieur paquet mais
laissez-nous vous arrive donc toi mais
voilà à faire aveu du fonds s'est passé
en corse est pas si là encore savoir et
âme je n'ais pas vue depuis hier
depuis c'est sans importance avant le
moyen maintenant un connaît pas son bon
vieux si ça n'allait pas marcher raconte
yeux ça pourrait bien arriver puis c'est
moi on ne m'enlèvera pas une chose de la
tête donc c'est que du fossé cherche à
nous mettre dedans il serait pas tenable
au grand frère seulement il a des
raisons pour nous le cacher on ne tue
pas mais par ben le combat il est
inadmissible qu'on lui ait fait une
réputation de chanteur
même dans le midi s'il est complètement
aphone seulement il a dû flairer la
vérité apprendre que l'opéra voulait
l'engager alors furieux d'avoir signé
avec toi il a trouvé d'autres moyens
pour t'amener à résilier son engagement
que de te faire croire qu'ils n'avaient
pas de voix elle est pas mauvaise mais
il la connaît du fossé heureusement que
tu as vu ça tout les toits peints ouais
c'est que nous ne sommes pas des
imbéciles
mais moi ça ne se fait pas en deux jours
mon dieu qu'il a à faire de la longue ça
pourrait arriver parce que c'est quelque
chose qu'il fera du tort à mon avis oui
je le crois très coureurs ce garçon là
tu sais pour l'avoir à croire que les
huit baies il suffit qu'ils aperçoivent
un cotillons 4 ici tu n'as rien vu à toi
eh bien il est une femme mais monde qui
tourne
oui comment j'ai rien vu c'est sa table
bosch la nommerait par non on est
maladroit il s'était passé n'est pas
parce que c'est sa femme un audacieux
landerneau ce n'est pas hier par clic de
l'apady à 6 6 6 a su au contraire et m'a
dit vous savez pas car elle j'ai l'air
de l'eba pas du tout c'est pas ça je
vous assure qu'il n'ya rien je te croit
thierry henry mais plus tu sais moi moi
je veux bien moi je m'en fiche
abbas est une bonne pâte mais c'est égal
toi méfie toi abou quadron ça mon ami tu
t'en fiches
moi je fais comme toi avec les
philosophes
vous voilà mon cher du concept
je vous ai entendu faire dire où là tout
allait bien moi je mets de la ville
comme jamais ta vie et nos maux
activerait je l'écris moi aussi dct
l'eau dans le réservoir
l'eau qui montait à la belle chante bien
comme vous d'ailleurs car vous avez une
voix sacré farceur ça éclate un état
êtes-vous à cet appel
moi pas plus que par exemple la voyons
pas de cachotterie 1 coupe en chine où
la daïra ne voulait cela d'en sortir qui
bat votre voix à vos sites web merci
j'avais bien entendu
alors allez-y l'espoir nous savons tous
que vous êtes d'autres ténors de la plus
grande valeur moi mais c'est pour rire
tatata faites pas les innocents nous
savons que c'est dans votre jeu et c'est
inutile on ne vous lâchera pas à pas la
peine de vous entêtez à ça il y tient et
les reds un peu pour voir la plupart ils
font tourner en bourrique
j'aimerais bien c'est un peu faux mais
parce qu'à dix coups modère pas conduire
à un décor derrière voyez bien que vous
avez une voix superbe mois d'ailleurs
votre réputation est faite dans bordeaux
alors en bon bah ça je vous aurais pas
fait un si beau cliente engagement ou
pensez bien
c'est pourtant vrai ça alors c'est
sérieuse que venables sais que je ne
serai jamais douté lors aussi c'était
enfantin de vouloir nous le cacher ce qu
on s'ignore tooway voulez vous que je
vous dise et c'est positif dans le fond
j'ai toujours pensé que j'avais la pole
seulement à bordeaux quand on chante et
on me disait ferme ça tu vas faire
pleuvoir urbain toujours des hommes
vieux savon contrarier les vocations
doremi sont la cible au salut demeure
chaste début du jour le maire il varie
peu n'ayez pas peur j'en apprendrai de
oui c'est si bon une belle voix en
france vous n'avez pas ça quant à lui en
italie
si vous aviez été comme moi à la
chapelle sixtine un bout pas pourquoi
parlez-vous arabe
les paparazzis à l'échelle à laquelle
vous avez dit vous là j'ai dit si vous
alliez était comme moi la chapelle
sixtine n'avait jamais bien entendue
comment vous avez été à la chapelle
sixtine vous sentez comment je dis
chanter chanter arriver encore je chante
parfaitement parfaitement saluer c'est
bon t'as dis pas fréquent qu'on a perdu
mais j'ai entendu au genre vient par le
pauvre sous mais pour en revenir à la
chapelle sixtine
vous savez sans doute que les chantres
ans environ nous savons oui eh bien vous
ne pouvez pas vous faire une idée de
l'intensité d'harmonie qui se dégage de
ces massy purent ainsi assembler qui
chante toutes leurs parties avec une
homme va il les chante de mémoire
évidemment mais comment un garçon comme
vous at il pu avoir l'idée d' entrer là
dedans ou à la chapelle sixtine et bien
figurez-vous que j'étais à rome j'avais
déjà un peu le spleen je venais
d'apprendre que ma maîtresse une femme
qui m'avait jurer un amour éternel
barnett fil avec un dentiste napolitains
ont pas parce que c'est un désespoir da
vous mettez vous à ma place dans la rue
pour me tendit alors je me suis mis à
arpenter les rues de rome
seul décourager des goûters lavier
défendre soudain qu'est ce que je vois
devant moi la chapelle sixtine dame pour
un homme qui est tout seul à rome avec
le spleen en plus une maîtresse en moins
c'était encore une ressource vie
médiocre
je me dis c'est le ciel qui n'envoient
entre 11 à la chapelle sixtine comme ça
la vie et dont la vocation à les jeux ne
l'est pas regretter au jamais jamais je
vais vous dire monsieur que j'ai trouvé
là une des plus grandes secousses de ma
vie je vous crois je n'étais pas sitôt
entré monsieur que je me suis senti pris
par tous et chantera la voix céleste
terrasse et démonter je n'étais plus un
homme monsieur g terre en jeu je ne sais
plus ce que j'étais et on va chercher
pas aller
au total six mois au point que je n'ai
même pas fait attention à ce qu'on me à
exécuter qu'elle spartiate
c'est égal je ne l'oublierai jamais
mais c'est tout à fait ça ça vous donne
qu'une femme lit des eaux et moi et moi
et moi qui croyais que vous faisiez la
cour à la modernité
je saisis par le rapport figurez vous
j'étais persuadé qu'au bout cultive y
est madame packard el assad le moment
qu'aux amis pauvre ami bombarder je vais
écrire l'opéra vous tâchez d'être un
comédien on espère ça m'est égal de
galère maintenant nous avons le secret
mais si l'internaute ici non non non non
pas tout le temps j'en ai rêvé en bas il
a raison il faut se réserver pour la 2
occasions on s'explique ce pauvre 10
pouces et allons faire le trou des
halles on va car elle rue j'en ai assez
moi j'étais pris ce matin on y reprendra
plus ce matin à 5 heures comme c'était
convenu après une nuit blanche ou à peu
près j'ai eu des cauchemars toute la
nuit j'ai rêvé d'hippopotames la 5
heures je saute à bas mon lit tout
palpitant je descends dans la serre je
me dis elle va venir je l'attends j'ai
attendu comme ça jusqu'à 8 heures je
vous demande un peu ce n'est pas
l'intention de venir ce n'est pas la
peine fatigué son mari et l'autre agité
leurs mouchoirs j'allais vomir madame
vous savez c'est comme il faut de faire
poser les femmes voilées force le
monsieur wiggers j'ai attendu et
j'aurais peut-être attendu encore
bibiche bibiche ah oui la grosse ville
oui mais biche qui a surgi à trois
heures selon la cire comprenez que s'il
avait une rage de dos qui l'empêché de
dormir
alors moi j'ai déjà vu névralgique pour
sauver les apparences et nous nous
sommes prononcés toutes les deux noms
large
enfin comme elle n'avait pas l'air de
vouloir s'en aller qu elle nous
conseille une couche je suis parti pour
ne pas éveiller les soupçons
d'autres madame mois trois heures j'ai
attendu trois heures c'est pas une
humeur se savait attendu vous oui
parfaitement
dans la serre dans la série y en a pas
plusieurs suppose mentonnaise non mais
vous ne m'en fais mais c'est vous qui
voyez vous donner les gants c'est madame
tenez prenons mais c'est pas canal pour
juge en thèse générale une femme à
cordes un rendez-vous un monsieur n'est
ce pas et bien ce monsieur croix de bon
goût après avoir sollicité sur mode et
vous donne y parvenir
et bien ce monsieur est un paltoquet
ferme et et quand c'est la femme la
vente est toujours l'homme 14
aussi je suppose que ma femme oui parce
que je peux bien vous dire ça vous a pas
dit qui est sans importance
ma femme ma femme vous donne un rendez
vous n'y allez pas pour demain stocker
mois le mari je vous en secret devrait
m'a pas choqué tout de même apprendre de
quoi parle
bien qu'une gamme du fossé connais bien
et qui s'est pas marié mais oui c'était
drôle et le nom du mari ça non
je répéterai pas parti je m'en moque je
le suis c'est landerneau assez marié
quel type tous aveugles et c'est à vous
que ce rendez vous elle tombe bien
amandine 1 je comprends que vous ayez
renoncer dans son état est condamné ce
qu'ont donné
non c'est trop fort c'est moi qui ai
raison cemac et or ont fait poser on me
fait des scènes à bout voilà monsieur à
l'envol autres à 13 heures vous êtes
qu'est-ce qu'il ya on sait jamais ce
qu'elle veut c'est ok hosking à ce qu'il
y a fallu faire la même question par
exemple j'aime à croire que votre
hautement d'une est détraqué ne l'a plus
d'être inquiet des deux n'est pas celle
qu'on pense en est ce que ça fait pendue
qui 5,3 me dit qu'on aurait l'enfermer
non vous savez si c'est pour me faire un
tour d'horloge
je faisais là trois heures je dormais
bout d'homme à trois soeurs vous aux
cadors c'est plutôt leur même jeu je
rêve ou c'est un n'essayez pas de me
faire croire que vous rêviez de moi non
je l'avais dit potable
il ya une nuance sipa même vous rêviez
pas même deux mois et qu'un pendant que
vous ne préfériez des hippopotames je
vais y est c'est ce qu'on m'a dit une
rage de dents d'or non prétexte je
payais je vous dis alors que répondez
vous à ça si c'est pas de ma faute
qu'elle est grincheuse quand elle n'a
pas dormi et monsieur c'est votre pote
permettez de communes d'ath le
contredisait pas c'est pas paris tu
viens d'inde
ah bah voilà voilà voilà la jure
l'injure a admis aux allemands lui à la
fin du fou vous avez déjà ça de moi vous
me méprise mais non mais non du tout
quel patinoire vous n'avez pas dormir je
sais c'est très ennuyeux
oui enfin je sais ce que c'est ça m'est
arrivé aussi vrai du faux c'est ça tient
ou ça vous est arrivé mais il me doit
encore wispa on se tourne d'un côté
d'autres oui on ne sait pas comment ce
maître oui on a chaud la peau nous brûle
on tourne sans oreiller et puis on finit
par se lever à oui c'est tout à fait et
ba c'est ça c'est le café vous ne
devriez pas prendre de café le soir nos
cafés la concierge à bordeaux ça lui
fait le même effet
tu maintenant elle n'est pas l'essentiel
ces athlètes qui déménage or madame
expliquons nous suffit dutil messieurs
pas car elle qui n'est pas intéressé
dans la question a eu soin de vous dire
votre affaire mais je vous assure j'ai
rien à me reprocher j'étais à 5h dans la
serre vous n'étiez plus à part rien ça
trois heures de retard
on va tirer ça vous arrive être exact
comment vous dire c'est un coeur quand
on vous donne rendez-vous à deux noms
non pardon à 5 à 2
vous savez bien à ça que j'ai compté les
raies et le côté vous avez trop marquée
à mes jeux je n'ai fait que deux raies
mois de sur la wii mais trois sur
l'autre ce qui fait 5 à mais permettez
moi je n'ai pas ce n'est pas payée l'an
dernier c'est l'autre que vous voulez
dire
landerneau dépareillés comment comment
bien mais non vous avez fait de ré sur
pacarel 3 / landerneau ce qui fait ça
mais je vous dis que je n'ai pas ri guy
lambert noro vrai mais par walt jeu je
ne meurs stupide crillon au prodige et
recevez mes excuses on va les accepte
et moi qui vous maudissent eh ben moi
pouvait peut-être que je me gêne et aux
amandes mon amant du monde intel menti
oui lamandi mon amant dit encore vous ne
voyez donc pas que vous êtes coupé je me
suis coupé moi pour ça ça saigne
amandine mais parce que c'est non mais
tout parce que je laime on a mangé oui
oui des moyens qu'il a battu voulez vous
que j'aille le dire au laissez moi c'est
une forme partait partir moi quand
j'aurai passé ma vie à vos pieds jamais
donné je suis avant tout on s'en doute
n'a pas cadré
il voit surgir et vous le maritain série
marion une voyons pas l'intérêt de vous
voir à ce n'est que parce que pas car
elle me vois pas ce que tu l'as vu ça a
l'air bon la brute en haut mais les
tombes allait enfin veigneau de
l'échappée de la chapelle ovni poseurs
baa
il est un peu de propositions mais plus
j'en rigole en plus sûr surtout ne
croyez pas que j'aime votre femme vous
avez pas bleu j'avoue que les apparences
sont contre moi mais c'est pour sauver
une situation
c'est sa femme que j'ai je vais vous
l'avez pas je dois être bon vivre ça se
voit aussi six mois et vu au genou de
madame c'était pour détourner les où
sont à karel drôle de façon par exemple
il apprend qu'anne ne blesse notre
entraîneur je suis calme parce que je
sais qu'il n'est pas dangereux est
essentielle si l'on voit au fond
monsieur je préfère je me moque de votre
femme comme d'une guigne
je vous demande pardon parce que je vais
faire c'est pour sauver une situation
aux yeux du mari mark martin je t'aime
[Applaudissements]
puisque je vous dis je les prenne une
masse de partout tu es belle je
m'appelle a menti monsieur amandine
amandine semader blanche je m'appelle
comment ma faim car elle sait vous un
bandit ne sais quel pétrin
monsieur payet mais mais continuez don
de vous ça m'est bien égal à rémy allait
nous ne sommes pas jaloux nous ne sommes
pas des loups quand et où je t'ai
chapelle puis ça se moque de moi comme
enjeu qui comprend plus rien comment on
présente une grosse marque et l'exquise
amandine la grosse mare se trouve être
l'exquise attendait non je n'y comprends
plus rien la grosse mare devient la
grosse amendis l'exquise amandine
devient l'exquise marque la femme de pas
car elle devient la femme de l'autre
pendant que la femme de l'autre devient
l'ont fait à n'y plus rien comprendre ou
alors c'est qu'ils se trompent pas
possible c'est un tour de passe-passe
qu'au manque c'est non à qui je fais la
cour qu'elle marie et j'étais sur le
point de tromper quel est le serin qu'il
faut soigner enfin comment sont-ils
marier tous ces gens là d'être bien sous
le régime de la communauté des femmes le
libre échange dans le mariage d'un avec
le faudrait
bonjour monsieur du faux c'est à vous
voilà bonjour ça va pas mal et vous
merci alors tant mieux tant mieux et
vous vous portez bien comme je viens de
vous le dire mais c'est vrai vous venez
de me le dire mais je ne vous l'avez pas
demandé comme on a l'air bête d'entendre
vous demande pas comment vous allez vous
répondait merci heureusement que ça
arrive tous les jours et vous n'avez pas
vu monsieur pacarel gitanos temps là
vous êtes souffrent vous voulez de la
gombe
merci mon cher la loi vous me dit que
vous êtes là je descends 4 à 4 vous
serrez la main et vous annoncez votre
fiancée pendant que ma page sais je suis
en train d'écrire une lettre à important
que votre mère l'a bien battre ça je
n'en ai pas attendu mais j'allais vous
dire ma demoiselle bien mais une deux
trois catherine de 3,4 à gia alors mes
enfants je vous quitte mon cher ami au
début dit mais pas dans votre situation
on peut vous demander salariés vous ce
sont deux fiancés l'espagne pour les
laisser leur épanchements même pas il
est convenable de ne pas les abandonner
complètement à eux mêmes usages c'est
une étiquette
alors vous allez surveiller en prenant
soin de ne par les généraux promeneurs
ici de long en large mais sans vous
mêler à leur tête à tête on n'est pas à
déranger leur conversation
si tu me vois la bonne d'enfants pour
annuler eh bien rien de nouveau rien
j'attends un joint jusqu'à nouvel ordre
nous continuons à dissimuler
moi je n'ose pas dire à papa j'ai fait
ça vienne de votre côté c'est comme moi
avec maman je préfèrerais que ça arrive
à tous vous soit vers l'air d'un tattoo
il est évident vous n'avez rien de ce
qu'il faut pour être mon époux passé
comme vous je reconnais que vous êtes
très gentille mais vous n'êtes pas du
tout mon pti d'abord vous avez le nez
trop long
et moi j'aime que les rousses sont fait
peur jeudi 12 mai et puis je n'aime pas
les peintres on ne peut pas les toucher
sur son raid à couleurs avec moi comme
patrie je n'aime que les cocottes parce
que là au moins on est sûr d'en trouver
de la couleur vous avez dit coco ho
pardon j'aurais dû tourner la langue
ça m'est égal je ne dois pas savoir ce
que ça veut dire mais qu'est ce qu'il a
ce monsieur à se promener comme ça et
pas mal au coeur pour garçons c'est
qu'il est jaloux
il croit que je dois vous épousez
elle-même lui il me l'a fait sous entend
un landon et vous moi d'amis ne me
déplairait pas alors fake le lui ce nous
faisons entendre aussi maman devant vous
moi ça m'est égal je n'écouterai pas
après tout ça n'est que pour le rassurer
on n'a pas le droit de laisser souffrir
son prochain quand on peut calmer sa
souffrance
oui oui allez allez vous m'appelez
mademoiselle oui je tiens à vous
rassurer vous des champions est bien
calme et coup monsieur donne confiance
et ne sera jamais non jamais jamais mais
pourquoi me dit vous tous à mademoiselle
mais parce qu'après votre aveu je n'ai
pas le droit de m'amuser d'un jeu cruel
tu dois vous faire souffrir
mangez bien vu mais vous étiez agacé
vous trépignez l'appui cinq minutes je
ne suis pas encore quatre mois j'ai
peut-être tort de vous parler de la
sorte
madame landerneau a toujours dit en
amour il ne faut jamais s'avancer il
faut laisser venir
mais en somme si vous tuez bien avancé à
plat monte on met les charmantes et moi
qui m'en n'était jamais aperçu respaud
si mademoiselle que vous parliez de la
sorte s'il n'avait pas tardé pas de pote
bob dylan et pat burns
on ne peut pas entrer dans cette maison
il part tombe immédiatement amoureux de
vos charmes et moi c'est plutôt pour lui
confier pas de personnalité s'il vous
plaît non ce n'est pas votre cas car on
avait bien vu tout de suite au mémo si
vous savez aussi quand vous m'avez fait
l'un de vos sentiments
moi je vous ai fait que quand on se
rappelle plus mais ici vous m'avez dit
c'est moi que mon livre est si jeune été
retenu par les charmes d'une jeune
personne alors j'ai compris tu avais
vous dis oui ou non oui oui oui je crois
bien je ne dis pas je le répète
j'avoue zen et bien voulez que je vous
dise moi aussi mais là vraiment elle est
de l'islande où il était président jean
laloux en vain de racheter par mes
genoux pour ma fille l'amour est un
sentiment immédiat une seconde m'a suffi
pour me rendre follement épris de
mademoiselle sur commande
c'est vous un peu qu'est-ce qui me
chante et ballet vous de ce groupe est
là et vous voyez je les relevés de
faction il a une drôle de façon de faire
sa cour par exemple monsieur vous êtes
l'ami de mon père vous ne me reposerai
pas j'ai l'honneur de vous demander la
main de votre ce mot bombe ou au bas
d'une pompe à béton
à ce gentil en fait je vais me marier je
lui ai versé pour toi réseaux mariant
tube de la marine c'est pour moi et
ballets soit choisie mais je peux pas te
dire au bel et bien non c'est fini
qu'est-ce qu'il arrive comme ça voilà
donc tous à un journal plus tard alors
qu'il ne viendra pas figure toi que
dupont c'est maintement danone julie
allait bien homogène et bien le coach à
elle est bien bonne foi est vraiment
bonne
deux magasins à la fin je crois vraiment
fois les seuls moments où on s'engage on
annonce l'engagement à l'opéra du fameux
ténor du jeton appointements de 6000
francs par mois eh ben je m'en fiche
vous obligé d'être hagen vous me devez
40 mille francs
moi je dédie le dédicace des 10 je ne
vous quitte pas mort je t'ai pas pouvoir
rester avec moi et être adopté en même
temps mais je ne vais pas le père un
juif adultes en moi bon alors ce que
vous faites ici un pique assiette au
monsieur quoi avez vous dit que vous
appeliez du fond c'est pas du faux ce n
est pas du shore mécanique du jeu tombe
c'est le nom donné à bas mais où part
dit que vous étiez le fils naturel de du
fond c'est moi le fils nat b e s que
vous avez été chercher ça madame c'est
au peuple enfin quoi défoncer la cafice
et ben justement jamais dit que j'avais
un frère ce fils et moi oh
commencez-vous le cadenas qui a trait en
été
comme mêlant vous n'êtes pas ténor moi
je sais pas chanter ooh
c'est trop fort
j'aimerais dupontel qui manque dans la
taylor et les substituts son fils alors
qu'elle voit à dire votre défense a
ajouté monsieur mon père oui qui m'a dit
vas faire ton droit à paris n'a jamais
parlé ténors il m'a seulement recommandé
à vous j'ai lettre au fond de ma mal
mais comme on est tout de suite offert
une situation extraordinaire
j'ai accepté parce que je suis sans
cérémonie oui mais bon télégramme mon
père n'a rien su tiburce tiburce le
télégramme que je vous ai donné il ya
quelques jours nous rend aux basses ne
l'a pas encore parti comme
l'administration est mal faite
monsieur le veut bannon déchu
maintenance télégramme imbéciles
monsieur est dur pour le télégramme
alors maintenant j'ai l'honneur de vous
demander la main de votre forme ça nous
ce que vous avez à me reprocher moment
après avoir chanté à la chapelle sixtine
moi pas mais c'est vous qui l'avez dit
maintenant j'ai dit que jamais été mon
bien mais sans tabac vous êtes bien
[Musique]
madame intercéder auprès de monsieur
pacarel pour qu'ils m'accordent à
mademoiselle julie ferme et d'avrillé
plate et en faisant voter ce budget
allait bien après tout mais c'est pas
grave c'est votre fille aux yeux bandés
ma fille est promise à monsieur magloire
dieu me choque pas car elle je suis très
honoré mais mademoiselle monsieur pas
contrarier les sentiments je demande la
main de votre seconde fille marie mais
j'en ai pas je suis passé
pendant ce temps je suis moi du
faussaire je ne dis pas non
je vais réfléchir à ma vie je n'ai pas
au chapitre la scélérate étudiants dit
dont vous me devez l'explication parce
que je vous ai pensé aux pieds de ma
femme c'était pour monsieur landerneau
j'avais un caprice pour sa part vous est
permis d'embrasser ma femme rien dit
parce que je pensais que c'était pour
détourner les soupçons de paccar est
alors ça va bien alors tout est pour le
mieux est là c'est égal je n'ai pas eu
de chance avec mon énorme et ça me
servira de leçon voyez vous mes amis que
vous achetiez des navets ou que vous
traitiez avec un ténor
demandez toujours avoir la marchandise
sait jamais ce que l'on risque acheter
champéry
com
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la pièce que nous avons eu le plaisir de
jouer devant vous ce soir et de georges
feydeau
le décor et de roger hart
[Musique]
les costumes de donald cardwell
[Applaudissements]
avec raymond acquaviva
sophie deschamps
anne rushmore
[Applaudissements]
alain feydeau
lucien barthe jean
[Applaudissements]
yvonne godeau
micheline luciani
[Applaudissements]
thierry le luron
nous profitons en scène jean laurent
cochet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]